歡迎收看趙華
我是趙華
我是Aaron
今天最適合做什麼呢
睡覺
欸 今天
乳球啦
對不對
天氣有點微涼之外呢
股市根本就沒有人想要交易了
這個成交量啊
突然又降到了五六千億啊
要不是尾盤有殺下來
可能有些人覺得有點壓力
可能真的就是
五千多億的成交量而已
沒有錯
然後相關的這個AI的概念股門
又遇到了近期的AI風波
那個走勢也很辛苦
但是說實話這些風波
古早古早以前
在這個AI發展的過程中
也常常被拿出來提
就是說AI如果發展過速的話
大家是不是不要
軍備競賽投這麼多
但是近期因為有發生了
AI自己去當駭客
投到別人家
結果呢
管它的那個主人
根本就不知道
後來才發現
對
所以就
真的很誇張
那個週末是連續
三四家的龍頭
全部都来发言
同意放缓
所以看起来应该是有压抑一段时间的
然后在周末一口气爆出来
就好像我们养了什么宠物
结果跑出去到别人家吃饱回来
我们都没发现
只觉得它越来越胖这样子吗
是这样吗
不是带三五个小孩回来
外面剩下三五个小猫
所以到底像这个礼拜
有AI的利空
也有生息的压力
是不是最后要解压缩的时候
我们就来看
要怎样才能解压缩
我们说到压缩档
就是点两下
它就会展开
要按右键按解压缩
对嘛
但是里面搞不好一大包
是可以拿来用的东西
是这样讲是没错啦
所以看礼拜四能不能
把那个压缩解下来
是
对啊
然后看一下
量能极动了嘛
最终利空测试
AI降速连准卫生息
是
然后又资金又大风吹
资安要买龙头
可是资安好难容纳大资金
等一下来聊一下
怎麼幫大家做宣布
我們先來看一下最近發生什麼事情
在週末的時候
這個阿莫迪
Enthropic執行長
直接發了一個3800字的長文
說我們應該要讓AI的發展速度降慢
這個AI圖是Enthropic做得上
為什麼他像花美男
然後只有馬斯克像本人
畢竟年紀也比較短
對啊 為什麼只有他像本人
然後馬斯克直接在Twitter上
也引用了他的文
然後說 agree
然後他就說阿莫迪是對的
然後這個奧特曼也同意
他說這樣我們可能這個
OpenAI的IPO案
會稍微往後延一下
所以目前來說這幾個大佬
都在想要讓AI的發展放緩
哎呦 我覺得不太對勁喔
三人成虎
是
對 一定必有詭計
所以這個川普也出來講話了
川普大哥
對 川普是大哥
這個黃仁勳最近在公開場合
有一個演講
在Podcast
他錄Podcast
然後呢這個川普就打電話進來了
對就說呢
這個都中國的陰謀
真的在
他真的這樣講
阿公的陰謀嗎
對對對
然後呢他也說啦
不是我這樣喔
是他真的在上面這樣講
大家可以去看他的影片
然後他說呢
美國呢
不能在與中國的AI競賽中退讓
是
所以呢他是
呼籲不要放緩發展
對他都不可以
沒錯
因為以前呢
大家可能是
核彈啊 數量在
在爭那個第一名嘛
現在算力最多就是第一名
對 所以呢
確實啦 以川普的角度來講
他肯定是不想要放還的啦
因為他想要美國一直
就是全球的地位領先嘛
所以目前看起來
有點尷尬
但我覺得市場會比較
是針對這個去做反應
因為大家都覺得
好 你AI要放還
那你是不是
資本支出會縮水
那資本支出縮水
是不是AI不發展了
那台灣是不是
因為AI而起
又要因為AI而落
所以整個半導體類相關的
美國或台灣
其實近期的表現都比較辛苦一點點
所以AI概念股跟這個記憶體
在昨天的表現都非常辛苦
昨天美國是大指數
大概都跌1%內就非半跌5%
因為看一下這個整個跌幅都比較誇張
然後美國的資安股表現就很強
台灣最近的安控或者是資安
或者是軟體股
近期的表現就比較強
因為大家就說網路安全
好這個是其中一個近期最大的事件
再另外一個就是這禮拜三到禮拜四凌晨最大的事件
好 但是其實上禮拜五啊
我本來以為差不多啦
因為大家看到CPI沒有什麼很嚴重的反應還漲了
但為什麼這禮拜又重新拿回來變成一個議題了
其實它公佈CPI的時候啦
股市是先煞後啦
對 可是先煞那過程中
其實那個利率決策就已經拉到八成九了
對啊 那就是這樣啦
對啊 就要省啦
然后石油价格又破百啦
对啊 破百就93.5%
就放给它烂这样
对对对对
所以目前来说啊
这个以FaterWatch的市场押注来讲
基本上升息应该是
蛮明确的事情了
但是现在有一个论点
就是所谓的
鸽派升息
是什么意思
就是预防性升息
是啦 是有这样想的
升了之后呢
叫什么 叫利空出镜
对啊
这行情就会活起来了
有一派是这样讲法
但我觉得不管是哪一派反正现在很明确了嘛成交量萎缩了嘛萎缩的重点就是在于联准会利率决策后譬如说礼拜四礼拜五那个成交量能不能开始放出来
放出来才有涨或者是跌
所以目前来说我觉得
升息如果是
大家心里已经有预期了
那大家可以去思考的是
真的升下去之后
会不会是迎来一个
短线的利空出境
是
那至少大家可能觉得
不确定性结束了
有没有机会
把资金重新投入股市
然后再来另外一个
就是石油价格
对啊 因为一直在百元以上了
我们前两集还在讲
说会不会破百 会不会破百
结果它就站在百元上了
那目前看起来石油价格
已经连续三到四天的时间
都在百元之上
这个对于大盘来讲
或者说对于科技股来讲
就会比较有压力一点点 通膨嘛
那另外一个呢
昨天美国不只是30年起
连10年起都一度占上了
5%的殖利率
其实蛮赞的
就是会觉得
如果你今天买一个无风险资产
而且这是十年
它两年的也4% 5% 4% 6%
两年的就风险很低了吧
更低了
这个是资产通膨吧
我放进去就5%
以前我们在拼的是高股息要5%以上
所以目前看起来
我觉得这个数字也是对于股市来讲
是一个蛮明确的压力
再来我们看到大盘
大盘近期股市
因为我们在上礼拜或上上礼拜
来跟大家讲就是
短线要看十日均
长线要看二十日均
那不好意思
这个在昨天跟上礼拜五呢
全部都跌破了
对对对
没关系你没来不算
不算是不是
这里十日均线嘛
周五的时候跌破
这里二十日均线嘛
都跌破了
但是到现在是收复不回来
今天是跌破月线
是的
所以目前看起来呢
以我们常讲的这一段的惯性周期
多方的惯性就结束了
对但是现在没有转空
我問你喔 這樣會像M頭嗎
好像每次都在問這個
其實我覺得不會
不會喔 為什麼
不會像M頭
如果真的要M頭
這個應該要從這裡開始畫
這樣會比較像
那也很像啊
這不會啦 這沒有很像啦
對對對
目前來說我們關注的是這一段
那現在已經來到這個地方了嘛
所以觀察幾個重點
第一個昨天有拉角
所以昨天低點很重要
452.0左右
452.0到454.0
然後呢
如果這邊真的跌破
大家記得喔
可能就會來回測這個前低的平台
這平台是在442.0
也就是说如果跌破
可能还有1200点的空间
那目前来说都还没有转空
因为这里新低还是高前低
这里新高也是高前高
也就是说真的要转空
这个低点会做跌破
那只要这边跌破呢
大家可能就
风险意识要稍微再拉高一点
现阶段我们把它归类在
这个成交量都在走萎缩的过程
是一个亮缩整理的状态
那当然比较不舒服
所以目前没有偏空
但短线上还是在整理结构的
那就看我们整理完
礼拜四礼拜五
有沒有一些激情人
能夠站回全部均線也好
迎來跟紅K表態也好
那就有機會在這邊
重新的一個打底
就在一個足底
另外貴買的部分
基本上除了年限之外
全部均線全部跌破
目前來說就是
之前跟大家講
它就是一個箱形整理
所以這個低點沒跌破之前
它就是在區間做震盪
那就會比較沒有這麼緊張了
如果這裡真的跌破
就要比較深一點點
对 所以目前看起来
贵买虽然跌破了一些均线
但还没有让它的整个
箱形整理去做转折
所以目前是不用太紧张的
这个低点跌破
大家可能在操作上
就要有一些防范的措施了
譬如说要有一些避险部位
或者说把一些手上的资金
再重新收回来
等于有一个新的好形态出现
再重新做介入
可是你左侧的想法
就会觉得很珍惜这种回撤的机会
对 因为基本面的状况
非常好啊
是
所以一旦回撤
感觉上对我们这种
比较在意所谓价值面的人来说
好像就是机会的到来
对 所以我觉得
以我的角度来讲
我就觉得
因为你右侧动能
对 形态还在就可以做
但是形态不在
我都会建议等形态转好再做
机率比较好
没错 没错
我觉得都可以
因为像我自己一些ETF的部位
也是边跌边卖
对
好 再来我们看到台积电
台积电呢
那這邊原本一度創反彈的
箱形區間突破
但如果碰這個高點沒有過
沒有過就算了
它還直接跌回到箱形區間內
對 所以目前台積電
又回到這個區間內受震盪了
那如果大家把台積電的
這個K棒再拉大一點點
你可以發現它整個震盪至少一季了
就是在高檔震盪一季以上
那目前來說
成交量也都是
跟這邊相比
都是呈現一個大幅度萎縮的狀態
所以台積電
目前也沒有太明確表現空間
那就看什么时候成交量放出来
同时往全支股做移动
才有机会做表现
另外就台达电
今天他跟别人长不一样
因为他前面也跟别人长不一样
他今天后来反攻了一下
是的
因为他有传出那个募资
结束了
所以有一些小反应
不过这个反应
大家记得
这个地方跟这个地方
还有这个地方
头头低
没错这个地方是哪里
这个地方就是季线
季线压着他
是的
也就是说台达电要好
首先第一關這個不能破
第二關先站回季線再說後面才有機會挑戰前高挑戰2000塊甚至去挑战前面历史新高因为目前给的大摩给的那个目标价还是在很高的位置
但目前股价确实比较不争气
那我们先一步一步来
先回季限再看这个地方
然后形成一个多方的格局
然后再去挑战前高
所以台下店目前来说
可能还是要再努力一下
好 当然这个是以动能的角度
对不对
如果是以就是越跌越便宜的想法
台积电应该就是一个代表
没什么问题的
台大电如果它能指稳
因为其实大家怕的是
台大电会不会再去侧底
对 如果它能指稳的话
事实上也来到了
以明年来看
相对合理本益比的时候
比较便宜的时候了
好 所以刚刚我们讲的是
为什么现在盘面特别的闷呢
这礼拜有一些事件要去克服
但是有没有可能像解压缩一样
一解开 里面是一个百花齐放的
其实AI不缺力多
所以现在的话
压抑我们应该要把握现在的时机
但最近盘面上如果说以动能派来讲
就是资安类股了
资安类股感觉上获利很好
可是成交率很小啊
艾伦等一下会教你
怎么样安全的操作资安类股啊
好来吧
我们最近啊
这个不管是美国还是台湾啊
有一个族群特别的亮眼
这几天
沒錯 澳門有分一些細族群
包含像是安控 安全監控的
比原算是資訊安全的
還有一個就是軟體股
最近這幾個族群非常強勢
為什麼呢 因為OpenAI在裡面
有一個Hogging Face
發動自主網路攻擊
它被OpenAI攻擊
它是一個社群平台 被攻擊了
沒錯 那再來另外一個就是
Enthropic它有對RubyGymes
然後直接就為了要進去裡面
他直接病毒侵入人家
那这个东西是
人类没有给他指令的
他自主觉得这样子做
会拿到他想要的东西
但是他手段中间过程
他是选择比较
我们不希望这样做的方式
就像是以前有部电影
就是女主角喜欢男生
他就拿到他的钥匙之后
就跑到他家帮他整理家务
听起来有点恐怖
然后又偷偷离开
然后男生回家的时候
就发现怎么家那么干净这样子
恐怖吗
蛮恐怖的
善意的善意的
不行不行不行
我自己成立
我自己整理
好 也就是說呢
大家對於網路安全這一塊呢
怕了吧
有點怕 蠻恐怖的
對 笑很開心
對
好 所以現在在討論
就AI有進入了一個
短時間啦
不知道長時間有沒有講
從AI的基礎建設發展轉到
轉到了AI安全網絡
應該要怎麼去做建立
也就是說現在
AI發展的速度已經快到
一些可能政策
或者說防護措施
是跟不太上的
那現在大家馬上就回來
檢視這件事情
所以這個Crowstrike
最近的表現就直接創一個新高
輝達股價就一根兩個跳空缺口
這個是一些資安股代表
跟目前AI股代表
反而是對比了
沒錯 所以目前來說
整體來講大家都在討論
怎麼樣在網路上
可以得到一份安全感
好 那當然華文勳
我們剛剛有說
華文勳其實還是堅持去
要持續發展的
對 還接到川普的電話了
沒錯 沒錯
OK
可是台灣的資安股其實很雜
然后个股很多
是 就小型股很多
是的 因为很多成交量
是真的很小
几十张的
然后我就会觉得
这个族群会比较
未来会不会有长线一个大波段
我觉得不一定
因为短线现在我们刚刚有提到
现在成交量萎缩
市场缺乏一个主流
或者是缺乏一个题材
那现在题材是什么
就是这些东西
所以近期的表现非常强势
那我们就稍微来看一下
就后面有没有哪一些
是可以
因为这个族群真的非常大
然后很多是
有一些名不见经传的
所以我们有去看一下
也可能在这些领域里面
哪些龙头
或者说哪些毛利是比较好的
有帮大家列出来
好 但大家如果有印象
今天涨停的这两家
就是上一波资安软体股
在涨的时候
说实话比较活泼的股票
滑金滑红资
那时候都连续锁涨停
因为他们的成交量不大
就好容易锁
可是这个族群里面
也有那种获利超过
一个资本额的好公司
是的
其實還有一堆
其實像以前那個大眾
其實基本面也很好
也掌握過一大堆
那京城大家可能就比較熟悉
好 台灣大
對 沒錯
不過今天幫大家講的第一個
就是這個01
01它是比較偏向代理的
它是代理了一些軟體的工具
包含了這邊微軟的
然後等雲端的平台跟工具
有一些訂閱跟軟體授權的營收
是就是開訂閱
開訂閱的方式
那不過01的基本面
它是比较偏好的
而且它比较成熟一点点
然后股价或者是整个公司的表现
是比较成熟一点
那目前来说啊
这个成熟
我不知道在现在到底好不好
因为大家现在一标就是想要
一字锁一字锁一字锁嘛
那最近一字锁的一些个股
都是比较小型的
稍微又再更小一点点
不过呢如果是大家真的是
对于AI这个长线上
是网路安全有疑虑的
或者是说它是一个
基本面比较好的
那01呢它基本面确实是
还OK的那不过呢股价技术面上在昨天出现了一个天亮对 这这两天蛮多都涨这样而且它是黑黑方或是上影线所以呢大家可以去注意几件事情
第一个
它是来到前高附近
还有这边
可能在前面有些套牢的人
在这边做一个解套的卖压
那不过呢
现在多方趋势是还在的
那今天呢
碰五瑞均线又愿意收缴
所以它还在全部均线之上
有些意思说呢
这一个大量位置啊
就会是短期要关注的换手量
如果这个地方
收盤价能够去做一个突破125块
那就是换手成功
那到时候再去做介入
其实我觉得不会太迟
因为趋势还在嘛
那你这边大量之后
隔天还是愿意收红
还是在全部均线之上
所以显示下方是愿意有人做接手
做换手
那要换手成功
这个大量就要做突破
所以这个高点只要做突破
趋势就还有向上的空间
这个是第一档01的部分
老牌的啦
二几年来都有配股息
是的
2027年EPS有机会挑战
这个到9块左右
所以目前本益比其實也不算高
好 再來另外一個就是中華資安
它這個長得真的超詭異的
平常就是我講幾十張的那種
對啊
對 然後所以它一千多張
就會看成是一個歷史天亮
是的 可是你可以注意
它的毛利率是47%
是高的
對 是高毛利率
而且它有一些關股的色彩
那2025年相關的這個SoC
長約監控
首度長過51%
續約率超過了九成
所以它有一個非常穩定的底層現金流
也就是說這種個股在還沒有這種利多出現之前
第一個它成交量沒有很大
但第二個它基本面很好
所以比較偏向純股的方向
但現在動能有拉出來了
當然今天還有很多什麼安基資訊
其實都是跟資安比較明確的相關的個股
那今天全部都開高走低
反而是軟體股可能比較沒有沾到邊
今天的表現比較強勁一點
所以中華資安一樣跟剛剛提到的那個01一樣
這裡首次爆了一個大量
爆大量過程中要幹嘛
就是看能不能换手成功
也就是说这边已经要先做一个
缩链均线乖离的动作
那缩链乖离完
如果均线跟上有一个动能
能够让它带通去突破前高
这里呢趋势应该就还有下一段的机会
这个是大家回去可以去观察的
也就是说明后两天大家不用急着介入
等均线跟上
然后等看这个高点能不能去做一个消化
到时候量价如果都还是维持一个出量的状态
再去做介入就好了
对那长线上来讲
它其实比较偏向就是买着
然后就稳稳的一个公司
是 好 它就叫资安嘛
中华资安
其实我觉得感觉上
有点像军工
就是很久很久很久都不发动
可是有时候一发动
真的是连续性的大涨
我觉得软体资安股
就很容易让人家期待
那个一大波的涨势这件事
而且它很容易就
开盘就一是锁
你想买那也是要三五根
他看有没有机会打开
对 所以我觉得资安
大家就稍微再观察一下就好了
这个就是之前大标的
股华金
他不是获利那么好
可是却很标
没错
他前一阵子呢
这一段时间
那个成交量
就基本上就是没有量
但是到这三天
量能全部都放出来了
那华金呢
他是目前有一些
资案的法规提高
跟勒索病毒防护升级
中端客户会对一些
零性源结构
跟云端备份资料的资本支出
会维持一个成长
那目前呢
企业有推动深层式AI地端落地的时候
需要仰赖这种SI厂商进行
高阶伺服器的那种部署
对也就是说他其实确实是有在做这些事情
那不过呢
我都回到一样的逻辑
因为短线上三根
就30%了
对那30%现在在讲的是AI的不好
那需要网络的好
所以在涨
那到时候如果这些利空那一些
Fate升息完了
成交量拉起来了
AI回归主流了
那大家要记得
这个资金要从哪里抽
也是从这些个股抽
也就是说我会不建议用追的
但是当资金重新轮回到AI的时候
这个会开始有资金的外移
开始走回落
那如果你还是觉得这个题材
长线它应该还是一个关注的重点
就趁那个时候回落再布局就好
因为已经涨上根了
我在这边叫大家买
好像也怪怪的
可是这个也是我观察自然股
或是说软体股里面
蛮重要指标
因为它就是以前的腰股
说实话
没错
所以我们可以去注意到了
技术面上当然底部确立
那当然这几个地方
都还有一些压力要去做消化
所以来到这个地方
那已经短线又涨三根
就大家不用急着追
但是大家可以知道
有这档个股放入你的自选单
这样刚刚出现了一个
资金轮动的状况有走回落
那回落过程
当然均线都上完了
它如果启动一些支撑的效果
启动一些有机会
在新的一段
我们再去把握那一段行情就好
现在大家都知道
其实有一些软体股
包含像滑金是强势的
大家就记得就好了
好 其实也可以拿来做一些训练
为什么呢
因为像我之前也是在看军工的时候
刚发动一两根的时候
想说每次都是一日行情
就之后拉出来一大段
我觉得资安和软体股
就给我也是同样的感觉
大家不妨用技术形态去锁定一下
尤其是之前的小腰股
就是华红资 华金
有在发动
那可以回头去看那些
一年可以赚七八块
甚至一个资本额的公司
它光是殖利率保护
都还算蛮甜的
是
好 當然如果對今天
所有的資料圖卡
想要免費索取的話
歡迎訂閱一下
趙華艾倫說的YouTube頻道
我們會放在首頁的貼文欄裡面
讓大家索取